sur la trentaine alors tout à l'heure
alors on reçoit tout à l'heure pendant
une dizaine de minutes vous allez voir
ils vont nous faire un truc très
particulier dans l'émission les
chevaliers du fiel parce qu'ils seront
directs ensuite un sur d8 donc ils
partiront directement aux motos voilà
directement au théâtre donc marc-antoine
le bret nous allons prendre des
nouvelles d'autres grands duos comiques
et on commence par elie semoun qui a
vécu une expérience malheureuse enduro 1
bon 1 vous savez je me bats toujours été
salon de faire un geste en duo avec
quelqu'un qui malheureusement a mal
tourné puisque la personne m'a trahi
tout simplement je dois décider de les
donner la parole vas-y exprime-toi
traître et je le sais franck dumas super
oui c'est vrai il depuis les petites
annonces jeter qui tu es mais uniquement
pour faire un duo avec un partenaire
talentueux de bien plus grande envergure
et surtout qu'il ya énormément de succès
je parle bien sûr de maquettes et jean
claude le guen bistoufly
mais quand c'est antoine de caunes
bonsoir à bouchehr sud il sur toi tu de
khodjalou sachez que le grand journal
que j'essaie modestement d'animer n'être
aucunement en concurrence avec touche
pas à mon poste
en effet contrairement à vous nous nous
focalisons sur une certaine finesse
d'humour sur l'actualité et l'actualité
politique n'est ce pas mon cher jean
michel aphatie il vrai que tout grand
journal l'information tient une place de
choix pas sont d'ailleurs en revue les
14 secrétaires d'état que manuel valls
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est un jean
michel c'est un coussin péteur que j'ai
placé sous votre siège
comme quoi la formation et fidèle sumo
ristic peuvent faire bon ménage
voilà trait d'esprit qui laissera une
trace merci alors qu'ariane ya laurent
laurent ruquier les titres mondiaux
lookée mais il avait une bombe
ok c'est le meilleur en voix soul est
bon merci à tous les services dans mon
émission
j'ai mon duo de polémistes d'un côté la
féminité et de l'autre natacha polony
fut un autre avec qui on fait un beau
diot c'est nicolas bedos
allez-y salut ruquier j'aurais voulu se
soient reversés dans la gaudriole les
mon coeur ne bat plus qu'à moitié depuis
que je sais que natacha tu va s'en aller
que je n'en voyais plus la polony oui
elle va nous quitter
narus préfet raymond enragé orange et
marocaine qui enquiquine aimons aubure
de casse burnes aussi pour la remplacer
nous faut-il une grande gueule à forte
carrière forte crinière c'est donc
immédiatement pensé à enora malagré
rejoins-nous enora quitte je t'en
conjure ton pakistanais soit nous
rejoins-nous enora nous serons nul nous
serons griser par l'alcool bon marché
offertes par france télé à tension
sexuelle entre nous deviendra
insoutenable et dans une féline envolée
jeu bondirait sur toi tu es là roumain
sur un iphone en terrasse bien il aura
bon gré mal gré rejoins-nous et je t
aime y vient d'y contrôler nos coûts
sébacées nelson monfort alors force est
de constater qu'avec philippe tour de
l'euro nous formons un duo
complémentaire et détonnant n'est ce pas
mon cher fait peur quand de l'euro
atteint raison nelson qu'on écoute toi
tu fais des commentaires de fonds et moi
je fais des commentaires de filles ont
fait mais je tenais aussi à vous dire
que commenter les jo de sotchi en votre
compagnie a été un événement tout parti
qui a team et au nelson que c'est
extraordinaire
sotchi ingé déglingué de la rue score
pendant deux semaines